kenya's government has been defiant in
its response at the attack on a
university in which 147 people died the
country's interior minister said it will
not give into terrorism after Al
qaeda-linked al-shabaab group said it
was behind the killings well Simon Hayes
lock is a former advisor to the African
Union and he's here with me now Simon
Hayes like an appalling attack what's
your reaction to it well I think I'm
sadly it's part of this sort of
escalation or inflation of brutality in
the region I mean al-shabaab has lost
the headlines to Boko Haram and is etc
and this is part of that horrible you
know rise in what can you do to grab
back the headlines and I think in many
ways that succeeded I mean they've got
themselves back on the front row far as
the competition for media coverage is
concerned and isolated places like Yemen
etc and to get their story out so it's
part of that I'm afraid and clearly they
last made headlines in this country and
around the world with their attack on
the Westgate shopping centre which which
targeted Westerners predominantly in
what way is this attack different I mean
clearly it attacked Kenyans but what
would you say about their modus operandi
well I think it's actually pretty part
of the same narrative I mean I think you
know one as I said they're trying to
recapture some of the lost headlines
they've got two other organization
secondly it's part of the fact that
actually al-shabaab is actually on the
decline with in Somalia I mean it's
suffered a loss of most of the territory
that it used to control a lot of this
little more moderate nationalist members
have sort of left the organization you
left a much harder line much tighter
group who now find it easy to operate
outside of some Island than they do in
so this is sort of the global jihadi
element of our Shabaab as opposed to
some nationalist more moderate elements
inside Somalia and a number of countries
of committee troops to the African Union
force that's fighting in Somalia and yet
it appears to
Kenya that is attacked more regularly by
al-shabaab why is that well I think the
number of reasons I mean first of all
proximity it's very close northern Kenya
is broadly a Somali ethnic population
they speak Somali so there's a lot of
sympathy and there and there is a lot of
suspicion min party certainly in
southern Somalia about the reasons why
the Kenyans got involved and also the
Kenyans perhaps have not reacted very
well to the emergence of terrorism
Somali terrorism in terms of actually
acting in a pretty harsh way against the
Somali community which is only given
them sort of more could recruit some
more British so I think there are a
number of reasons and primarily it's
easy easy for them to operate there and
how will Kenyans be feeling presumably
they'll be feeling deeply vulnerable
this is a terrible attack 147 people
killed will there be any pressure from
the public on the government to pull
their troops out of Somalia I'm not sure
there will be pressure to pull the
troops out I mean there but there's
certainly a lot of Preston to do
something more more effective I mean
when nice to see that the tourist
industry in fact in in Kenya has been
devastated particularly on the Swahili
coast by these attacks in the past and
this is just another example of that
sort of thing I mean I think I I think
it's very difficult to see how they how
they will respond but I mean I think
that there will be I think it's quite um
it was quite encouraging to see from
your report that the were there was a
joint protest including Muslims within
Gabriel yesterday about the these
attacks because I think one of the
reasons that we need to be worried is
this attempt to isolate Muslims and
Christians with in Kenya and therefore
to create the notion amongst the
minority Muslims that they're being
isolated and therefore improve the
attempts of al-shabaab recruit Lee so I
think it's good that that demonstration
showed some form of unity between
Christians and Muslims and hopefully and
that's the sort of pressure that the
government will see they will unify
against this threat rather than separate
and fracture you've been an advisor to
the African Union and how would you
advise Kenya in this situation now well
I think they have to be they have to
think much smarter and much more longer
term in the way they approach this I
mean clearly they have some command and
control problems in terms of how they
respond to these attacks I mean they do
seem to be slow in reacting and they
probably do need to improve that sort of
those sorts of elements of how they deal
with it but also they need to tableau
the Somali population in a more
effective way rather than just trying to
show instant aggression against them to
pacify some other more more vociferous
members of the canyon community so I
think they need to think longer term
policy I mean one of the problems in the
northern areas of Kenya where this
attack in gorusuruz it's been long under
invested it's a classic place where you
know they need to improve the
opportunity and there is a big plan to
invest substantially in that area and
one of the worries of course is that the
city of deteriorating security situation
might actually prevent that from
happening because that shouldn't be the
case they need to invest and they need
to improve this of lot of audience
applauding canyons in that part of the
country and he talked about the desire
by al-shabaab that to grasp for
headlines again this kind of brutal
almost competitiveness with other
appalling groups as well doing similar
things and presumably one of the reasons
they want the headlines is that it acts
as some kind of grim recruiting tool
well it's it's not just recruitment it's
also funding I mean then they need to
get funding and you know it's it's it's
like business in a way you've got to
advertise you've got to be you've gotta
capture a zeitgeist in order to in order
to do that and so although it's horrific
I mean that I'm afraid that is it you
know recruitment and money is the thing
that keeps these organizations afloat
okay well Simon halo fascinating to get
your insights into what's been an
appalling attack but it's time and thank
you thank you very much